Isaac Newton laid the foundations of modern science.
He discovered gravity...
...and the principles governing motion, light and cooling.
He invented calculus.
Most of his work made a huge and lasting contribution...
...to the state of human knowledge,...
...but a few of his projects never made it any further...
...than the paper they were outlined on.
All generations that came after him would benefit from his innovations,...
...but none of them would ever use one that he outlined in his student notebooks:...
...his universal language.
When Newton was just beginning college,...
...he drew up plans for a language based on the nature of things,...
...rather than on mere convention.
We call an apple "apple" just out of habit.
The form of the word, the sounds in it,...
...don't tell you anything about what it means.
Newton's idea was to let the names of the same sort of things...
...begin with the same letter.
If, say, all fruits started with "a,"...
...words wouldn't just be arbitrary labels, haphazardly assigned.
You could know just from hearing a word what category of thing it belonged to.
Agnar?
Don't know exactly what it is,...
...but it starts with "a," so I know it's a fruit.